with the first season of The Rainbow six
Pro League about to wrap up Ubisoft is
giving PC gamers the chance to play
rainbow 6 siege for free I'm Lucy and
welcome to this breach and clear
gamespot news updates until April
seventeenth you can play siege as much
as you want to on please see through
steam or you play you get access to the
full game including competitive
multiplayer terrorist hunt and Angela
Bassett to download the steam version
head to its store page and click on the
image under the free weekend section on
you play open the clients and look for
the banner advertising the free weekend
event coinciding with this football game
is thirty-three percent off bringing its
price down to forty dollars the Gold
Edition is also on sale but at a
discount of forty percent making it 54
bucks this version of the game comes
with the season pass offering early
access to new operators as they're
released among other things Steve's
first released in December on pc xbox
one and ps4 since then it's gotten new
free content including new operators
features and a mouse so are you gonna
give sees your world this weekend let me
know in the comments below or come find
me on Twitter I'm at Lucy James games
for more on Rainbow six keep it gamespot